it's it's unbelievable the degree to
which our sanity depends on a
functioning sociological structure and
here's why well first of all you kind of
need to know what to do every day you
have to have a routine because you're an
animal you know on you know if you have
a dog or a cat dogs are really good
example this dogs like routine they like
to be walked the number of times a day
that they're supposed to be walked and
they get quite sick very rapidly if you
don't if you don't routinize they're
they're days children are exactly the
same way now you can overdo it right but
still you know you need to know
approximately when you should get up to
be approximately the same every day you
need to know approximately you're going
when you're going to eat you need to
know what you're going to eat you need
to know who you're going to eat with you
need to know where to buy your food it's
like 80% of your life 70% of your life
something like that consists of those
things that you do every single day that
you repeat and those are often the
things that people think about as the
trivial elements of their life but one
of the things I would like to point out
to you if you do the mathematics I did
this with a client of mine who was
having a hard time putting his child to
bed they were having a fight every night
and I knew by that time the studies
indicate that most parents only spend 20
minutes per day of one-on-one time with
their child now the reason for that is
that people are busy and it's actually
not that easy to parse out 20 minutes of
one-on-one time it's a lot bloody more
time than you think but that's all there
is 20 minutes he is spending like 40
minutes a day fighting with this kid
trying to get the kid to go to bed and
that's not very entertaining you know
you think why is just having a scrap
with the kid about going to bed but it's
no no no no no if it happens every day
it's a catastrophe so you do the math so
we'll say five hours a week for the sake
of argument just to keep it simple it's
20 hours a month it's 240 hours a year
that's six 40-hour work weeks that guy
was basically spending a month and a
half of work weeks doing absolutely
nothing but having a wretched time
fighting with his son trying to get him
to go to bed
horrible right that's just way too much
time
spend doing something like that if you
want to actually have a positive
relationship with someone because it's
just too it's just too punishing and so
well so you need a structure you need
predictability and you need more of it
than you think
just to keep you sane now if you're
lucky and maybe a bit odd you can
deviate 5% from the norm or 10% from the
norm or something like that carefully
and cautiously as long as the rest of
you is all well ordered in a normative
manner you might be able to get away
with that and you might be able to
sustain it across time and people might
be able to tolerate you if you do it or
maybe you'll get really lucky and you
happen to be creative but reasonably
well put together and people will
actually be happy that there's something
idiosyncratic and unique about you but
even under those circumstances mostly
what you want is to have a routine it's
discipline its predictable and bloody
well stick to it you're going to be way
healthier and happier and saner if you
do that and then the other thing that
you need because this is one of the
things the psychoanalyst got wrong I
think is that they overestimated the
degree to which sanity was a consequence
of internal being properly structured
internally you know because from the
psychoanalytic point of view you're sort
of an ego and that ego is inside you of
course it rests on an unconscious
structure but the purpose of
psychoanalysis is to sort out that
unconscious structure and the ego on top
of it and to make you a fully
functioning an autonomous individual but
there's a problem with that because the
reason that you're saying as a fully
functional and autonomous human being
isn't because you've organized your
psyche even though that's important the
reason that you're saying if you're a
wit if you have a well organized
unconscious an ego is because other
people can tolerate having you around
for reasonably extensive periods of time
and will cuff you across the back of the
head every time you do something so
stupid that people will dislike you
permanently if you continue and so what
people are doing to each other all the
time just non-stop is broadcasting
sanity signals back and forth right it's
like you smile at people if they're well
if they're not not only
behaving properly but behaving in a way
that you would like to see them continue
to behave you frown at them if they're
not you ignore them if they're not you
shun them you you roll your eyes at them
you manifest a disgust face you don't
listen to them you interrupt them you
won't cooperate with them you won't
repeat with them it's like you're
blasting signals at other people about
how to regulate their behavior so
frequently well it just makes up all of
your social interaction that's why we
face each other and we have emotional
displays on our face and we're looking
at each other's eyes and we know exactly
we know as much as we can about what's
going on with each other given that we
don't have immediate access to the
contents of their consciousness and so
partly what you're doing with your
routine is establishing yourself as a
credible reliable trustworthy
potentially interesting human being who
isn't going to do anything too erratic
at any moment and everyone else is
around there tapping you into shape
making sure that that's exactly what you
are and that's how you stay sane and so
what happens to people too if they don't
have a routine and they get isolated is
they start to drift and they drift badly
because the world is too complicated for
you to keep it organized all by yourself
you just cannot do it so a lot of our so
we outsource the problem of sanity and
it's very intelligent that we outsource
the problem of sanity because sanity is
an impossibly complex problem and so the
way that we manage the incredibly
complex problem is we have a very large
number of brains working simultaneously
on the problem all the time